[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from 2016. it's a blitz game
and it's from the ultimate blitz
challenge uh four player tournament
fabiana corona wesley so hikaru nakamura
and gary kasparov
brawled it out to see who can uh who can
take it all
and we're gonna discuss the the
standings a bit later but now let's
check out this game we've covered some
of the games from this tournament
another this one in particular it comes
as a suggestion from tux the penguin on
twitter
so thank you for the suggestion and uh
yeah let's check out
the the the game and let's see why is it
so nice to
always be attacking in chess so favi has
the white pieces
and he opens with e4 caspar of course
replies with the sicilian defense he
plays c5 we have knight to f3
uh d6 and now d4 so nothing out of the
ordinary here
captures captures we have knight to f6
knight to c3 and a6 kasparov goes for
the knight of variation of the sicilian
and h3 starting the atom's attack now
already you have h3 so you have support
for g4 later on for f4 and so on you
want to dislodge this knight and
uh well hopefully black will castle
kingside and you will be able to do some
sort of a kingside attack
so e6 we have g4 and now
bishop to e7 and while you can start
advancing the pawn immediately to g5
favi first starts with bishop to g2 but
now
kasparov will just removes the knight
knight after d7 and now there's a
problem you can't really advance those
pawns any further because there's no
knight here you cannot use the knights
to kick it away and then just continue
advancing your pawns
now the queen and bishop guard all of
these squares so you've kind of stopped
the white's expansion on the king side
so here bishop to e3 fabby just
continues development we have knights to
c6
and now queen to e2 saying that uh he's
probably gonna castle queenside
caspar of castles kingside and fabi
castle's queen side and as usual when we
have
castles on opposite sides of the board
that means it's going to be a
pretty pretty crazy game so here
kasparov eliminates the knight in the
center
knight captures on d4 bishop captures in
the now well there are
some of the moves you could play here
because parvo goes for queen to c7
basically you need the usual knight of
moves
bishop uh b5 bishop b7 rook c8 queen c7
uh because power starts with queen to c7
with
f4 uh fabi starts expanding on the king
side
and now b5 already preparing to dislodge
the knight with b4
and now the position has been reached
before and
e5 is the move that's exclusively uh
played here
uh opening up a discovery here towards
towards this rook now you could move the
rook you could play d5 and then white
continues attacking with f5
and then maybe b4 and who knows what
might happen here
however fabi after this b5 by kasparov
played the g5 and now g5 although it uh
serves the the same purpose you want to
continue your expansion on the king side
uh it doesn't come with any sort of a
threat also
it comes without tempo and kasparov is
free to do whatever he wants now because
it's different when you play e5 the rook
is under attack you have to react to
this now g5 is played
you don't have to react to anything you
can just continue with your own plan and
so kasparov does he plays the
strongest move there is in chess and
that is of course pawn to b4
uh now the knight is under attack and
here fabi could
probably still execute this e5 idea and
then try to mix it up
but he decides to go for knight to f4
knight to a4 and now kasparov uh well
shatters his dreams by playing e5
himself and now
fabi will no longer be playing e5 and
also
uh white really wanted to play f5 here
maybe even get f6 in but now with the
bishop under attack the f4 pawn will
fall as well
so here bishop to e3 captures on f4
bishop captures and now knight to e5
again blocking this e4 pawn
and this is just an excellent square for
the knight here then i control
so many squares uh it's uh well it's
just a wonderfully placed piece
uh here fabi goes for queen to f2 he
wants to get
he he gains control of the b6 square he
wants to get the knight to b6 attack the
rook and then shift the knight over to
d5
but kasparov will have none of that he
plays rook to b8 prevents the knight
from
uh going anywhere now the knight is
still stuck on a4
by keeping this knight there you're
basically saying that white is for the
moment to down a piece
uh so here fabi just continues attacking
on the king side we have
h4 and now kasparov needs to get this
rook into the game
so it only makes sense to get rid of
this bishop with tempo so here bishop to
g4
attacks the rook fobby needs to move it
rook to d2 the rook will
uh be much better on d2 than it was on
d1 you kind of need to defend that
c2 square the rook is coming to c8 so
you might have problems here
uh and here uh uh kasparov goes rook f
the c8 you could go with b3 right away
for example captures and captures but
it's uh
although uh it's uh obvious black is
better uh kasparov decides to prepare
this with rook f to c8
and now he's ready to push b3
so fabi uh beats him to the punch he
plays b3 himself
and now it's uh well it's kind of
different but kasparov has had many such
positions in his career of course he
knows how to
attack such positions so here queen to
a5
uh you could go knights to c4 right away
simply weaken that knight on a4 and then
go quit the queen to a5 but kasparov is
very sneaky he plays queen to a5 and now
prepares knight to c4
while also attacking the g5 pawn here
and this is gonna be
uh pretty pretty interesting so here
fabi finds the only good defensive
resource because other than all of this
you also need to worry about something
like bishop to d7 just eliminating this
knight because the knight cannot move
because sparrow grabs the a2 pawn and
that's it
so fabi plays the strongest move and
that is bishop to h3
uh but now uh kasparov just uh retreats
uh bishop to e6
saying that okay you can capture here
i'm just gonna improve my
presence in the center here by capturing
f captures on e6
but fabi now continues pushing on the
king's side and now
kasparov has his hands free to continue
the attack and of course he does it with
knight to c4 now attacks the rook on d2
uh and if you capture here then just
queen captures and your entire queen
side is shattered and
it's quickly going to be game over for
white
so instead after knight to c4 we have
rooked the e2
fabi just keeps the the rook safe and
then now comes
bishop captures on the uh on g5
now the queen defends it so there's
really no point in capturing
if you capture here it's basically game
over just queen characters here and now
it doesn't really matter what you do if
you go king to b1
uh we're just going to play knight a3
check and now after you move uh
just bishop captures on h3 and there is
nothing you can do
if you capture it then just queen the c1
will be checkmate and on the other hand
after queen captures on g5 if you go in
the middle of the board
then your king is already in the middle
of the board and well usually not
the greatest of ideas for example queen
e5 threatens queen to a1 checkmate
the knight is covering the d2 square so
one might capture on c4
but still queen a1 check king d2 and now
queen captures an h1 and this is
sufficient for black to just dominate
the rest of the game
so instead after bishop catches on g5
fabi grabs the knight here
and now kasparov can choose to grab the
knight here but also
he can just grab whatever there are many
things hanging here
so here he goes the ship captures on c4
now again there's the threat of knight
captures now the rook on e2 is under
attack
uh so what do you play here is fabi well
you could grab the rook here on c8 and
usually not usually but sometimes the
most obvious move is the one you should
play
but maybe not here because if bishop
captures on c8 we're going to capture on
a4 now bishop captures and g8 rook
captures on c8
and if he has the engine this uh
position is the comp
this position is a dead draw but of
course in a blitz game when you when
you're playing this against kasparov and
he's attacking you
this is not a dead draw it's very
unlikely that you
you will be able to survive this so uh
instead after bishop to c4
bishop captures and g5 was played by
fabi but now
queen captures on g5 with check you
could also grab the knight here because
sparrow chooses to
grab this one with check and now
the reason why he did this because there
is one move that fabi can make to
survive the attack but it's uh such an
unusual move
and you can try and you can try and
guess what the move is
so even feel free to pause the video and
try to find this idea for fabi
while i give you a couple of seconds
here
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations
on finding this incredibly difficult to
spot defensive resource and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to d2 it's uh such a crazy move
i know that uh but but it it works this
is
this is the only good move for fabi we
played rook to e3 because well
it's a blitz game and even if it wasn't
it's hard to you know
spot such things okay of course you
would find it in classical but that's
besides the point
uh so here point is that uh after rook
the d2
uh the usual bishop to d3 stuff
would not work because here you can just
eliminate the rook for example captures
captures and
king b1 you unpin and now there is no
captures on c2 because now the rook also
defends the sea dupont it's not pinned
however uh with the move fobby played
rook to e3
this is now a bit different because now
uh now you can just
bust the position open with b3
kasparov uh chooses the other move he
chooses bishop to d3 but now it's
different now you don't have the rook
also guarding the
uh the the c2 pawn and also uh here the
uh the most obvious is the correct way
to go here
uh fabi needs to grab the rook and after
for example this is captured
find this c3 idea but good luck finding
c
c3 in the blitz game uh now it's uh very
counter-intuitive to move the pawn in
front of your own king like this and
there's a rook on the c file but it
works if b captures then you've closed
off the c file
you no longer have to worry about that
rook and if something like bishop to b5
we just go after the knight here
doesn't matter rook to g1 this rook to
g1 is always in the position for example
queen h6 king the b1 now and if the
bishop is
if the bishop captures the knight now uh
rook eat the g3 and that's it
now we just win because of g6 we're just
gonna capture here
and after h captures queen to f5 now
with a triple attack on the g6 pawn we
attacked the rook here
and now whatever you play we're just
gonna grab here captures captures and
captures and now we win the game
captures captures for example
we're gonna capture here and the queen
will beat the the rook and the bishop
uh but like i said uh i'm only showing
you guys this for fun
in a blitz game it is of course
impossible to see such things so here
uh fabi played a queen to g3 he offered
a queen trade but now it simply doesn't
work because now kasparov just crashes
through
uh rook captures on c2 with check king
to d1
and now queen captures an h5 again with
check
uh queen to g for blocking and now even
queen to e5
threatening checkmate with queen to a1
so fabi has to eliminate
the bishop now the rook is also under
attack but now kasparov just plays
rook captures on a2 now queen to a1
again the threat of checkmate
so rook to d2 fabi creates a square on
e2 for his king but
now queen to a1 with check king e2
now we capture the rook with check
captures captures and now of course we
grab the rook
and now if you look at this position yes
fabi does have a knight in the bishop
for the rook but he's also down
some five pawns so here knights the b2
fabi needs to bring his uh
pieces now into the game to try and
activate them somehow
but queen h2 now you have to defend the
knight so bishop to g2
blocking the queen's check and now h5
trying to get the queen away from the
defense of the bishop here
so queen g5 and now comes queen to e5
offering a queen trade and fabi has to
accept because the knight is also
hanging on b2
so here fabi grabbed the queen we have
captures captures and bishop to f1 now
attacking the a6 pawn because part of
just advanced it
to a5 with bishop to c4 and here
kasparov just played
h4 and it was in this position and move
40 that fabiano caruana resigned to the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the reason you resign is because you
can't really stop the h pawn
uh i know you guys really like it when i
finish the games so i'm gonna
try and and to do it in the shortest way
possible for example if we stop the pawn
from coming to h3
we can just uh play something like rook
to c8 or rook to d
it doesn't really matter if rook to d8
to check king's gonna go back we're
gonna go rook to c8
and now we're getting to the c3 square
for example king b3
rook c1 attacked the bishop and it
doesn't matter where the bishop moves
we're just going to play
h3 and that's it for example bishop
captures rook c3 check
we're going to pick up the bishop here
and that's it now the end game is of
course completely winning
uh rook against the knight it's
unquestionable plus you have all of
these spawns it's uh
uh it's pretty pretty much
self-explanatory
uh so after this uh h4 move fabio
resigned and
an excellent victory for gary in this
brutal brutal uh sicilian uh game in in
the atoms attack of the sicilian
and that's the thing with the sicilian
you play the sicilian in one moment
you'll be winning one moment you'll be
losing but
uh you'll be you'll always be fighting
uh so yeah
now once again i hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank akram the
pilot kd nuggets derek king
zhang and david kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the the coverage of the
morphe saga checking up on your one of
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world next we have the ftx
uh uh crypto uh chess cup uh where
we're gonna have a lot of very very
strong players it's supposed to be the
strongest tournament so far
and with the biggest prize fund it has
220 000
price fund plus uh 100 000
in bitcoin and okay with the current
market crash could be a bit less
but uh you know it doesn't really matter
i think it's still going to be
uh the the the most pricey tournament
ever
but we'll see uh so i hope you guys
enjoyed that thank you again tux
thanks for the for the suggestion and
see you soon guys enjoy your sunday
saturday